let's take a brief moment to look at the
big picture of what we've learned now
we've learned a whole bunch of new terms
so far under models we've learned about
observables computed observables and
observable arrays now we really haven't
learned anything new regarding the view
model it's just our functions that we
need to run sometimes but we definitely
have learned something new about our
view we've learned about bindings now
just as a quick review our observables
are the variables that we're storing in
the model but rather than them being
simple variables we're utilizing
knockouts observables functions in order
to keep track of when things change we
have computed observables which are
computed whenever they're accessed based
on the value of other variables our
observable arrays are very similar to
observables we want to use those
whenever we have repeating elements such
as multiple cats then if you add a cat
or remove a cat knockout we'll know
which one change and it'll re-render the
view automatically and speaking of the
view bindings are the things that tie
this together with our models via our
view model declarative bindings are the
data bind equals blah blah blah now that
we've done this bigger picture review
let's go ahead and dive into computed
observables and see what they're like in
practice